overdoses relapses and Rehab doesn't
sound like a recipe for a successful
comedy But Chuck Laurie pulled it off
for eight seasons with his Smash Hit mom
if you've ever dreamed of making it in
Showbiz and need a bit of inspiration
check out Chuck Laurie's story Laurie
the creator of mom along with a host of
other hit sitcoms spent many years broke
and struggling before finally breaking
through in his mid-30s as he told the
Lansing State Journal I remember vividly
what it's like to put 38 cents in the
gas tank and drive to my second cousin's
house so they would feed me before
hitting it big in television however
Lori spent some time dabbling in another
creative profession songwriting and if
you're wondering whether any of his
songs became well known we've got four
words for you Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles yes if you've ever gotten the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles theme song
stuck in your head you can thank Lori
who co-wrote the catchy song that helped
Define the franchise as for his comedy
writing dream that didn't really happen
until he got a job writing for the
groundbreaking sitcom Roseanne a major
break that opened doors launching him on
a career trajectory like no other after
Roseanne Laurie went on to become one of
the most successful sitcom creators in
history responsible for the hits Grace
Under fire Sybil and Dharma and Greg but
Lori really hit the jackpot with Two and
a Half Men And The Big Bang Theory the
pair of Mega hits which gave him the
Hollywood cred to make Mom happen and
even though Laurie is a rarity a
sitcom's fangali with multiple Mega hits
under his belt any aspiring Rider can
find inspiration in his rags to Rich his
tail
before Mom Anna Faris was best known for
her roles in comedies like just friends
The House Bunny and the scary movie
franchise with her distinctive comedic
chops and bubbly blonde Persona she was
the first actor CBS approached for Mom
Ferris told pop sugar that her husband
at the time actor Chris Pratt actually
read the script for Mom before she did
and by the time he got to the second
page he was convinced the role was
perfect for her saying honey whatever
you're doing stop now and read this even
though television has come a long way
since the days where everything edgy was
on HBO Ferris and Janie agreed that Mom
dealt with risky issues for Network
sitcom during a joint interview with
Larry King when King asked Ferris if she
was ever surprised by the content of the
show she revealed that she was
constantly shocked by how far the
writers were willing to push it saying
on a weekly basis when we get the new
scripts I always say are we sure CBS is
okay with this
before Mom Allison Janney was best known
for her role as White House Press
Secretary Claudia Jean Craig also known
as CJ on The West Wing fans may be
surprised to learn that she didn't have
her breakthrough role on The West Wing
until she was 40 which is pretty unusual
by Hollywood standards Janie did have a
steady stream of supporting movie and TV
roles before then but nothing as big as
the West Wing which eventually led to
Mom
on Mom Allison janny's character Bonnie
had long flowing auburn hair her quaff
actually became synonymous with the
character which was a bit ironic
considering that it's not even Janie's
real hair yep the actor was wearing a
wig the whole time and her co-workers
didn't even know Jenny's real hair is
actually a beautiful shade of natural
silver and when she showed up on set
without the wig one day The Producers
apparently freaked during an appearance
on The Tonight Show starring Jimmy
Fallon Jenny told the tale how are we
gonna do what you should have asked us
before you did this to your hair and I'm
like guys I've been wearing a wig since
season one but no one nobody knew it as
a recovering addict himself mom was a
very personal show for Chuck Laurie who
got sober himself at the age of 47 as he
told TV Guide sobriety is a big part of
my life and it's been that way for
almost 13 years I'm eternally grateful
I've been able to find this in my life
I'm trying so hard I quit drinking I'm
going to meetings as far as how his
personal recovery Journey relates to Mom
Laura I told indiewire broken people
trying to repair their lives I can
relate to that I think we're all in the
process of doing a little mending
excuse me no one's going to be snorting
any fat rails while I'm here and as
Janie told Indie wire in another
interview it feels like a very grown-up
show for Chuck Laurie I had no idea that
we were going to be going to the places
that we've gotten to go with Mom
in Show Business like any other business
success breeds success and in Chuck
Lori's case having so many hits on his
resume gave him the freedom to take on
riskier stuff in other words shows like
two and a half men gave him the freedom
to make Mom Laurie told indiewire that
to challenge himself creatively he
needed to tackle something different
something that would force him to step
into new areas of Comedy I am at a point
in my career where I can take some
chances if you're going to experiment do
something that is Meaningful to you if
you fail you did something meaningful to
you and with Mom he did just that
someone's spoiling themselves actually
it's for my mom
she's a drug addict who just got out of
jail
oh
back in the 1970s legendary TV producer
Norman Lear was a household name he had
many Creations to his name but none is
groundbreaking as All in the Family
which dealt with topical issues and
proved that TV sitcoms could be
intelligent and thought-provoking Chuck
Glory often credits Lear for inspiring
him to create similarly edgy sitcoms
proving to the world that television
doesn't have to be predictable and it
doesn't need to be insulting to the
intelligence of the audience in an
interview with variety Laurie said that
with Mom he wanted to tell stories that
could take place in what he calls a
Norman Lear World in other words realism
rather than fantasy you know the
definition of insanity yes I know the
definition of insanity I live with you
Lear now 100 years old and someone Lori
considers A friend brought a reality to
the sitcom format that had never been
seen before and much like Lori has done
with Mom Lear made history tackling
tough subjects on TV as well in an
interview with the Los Angeles Times
Lear noted people will tell you you
can't do just about anything mention
abortion have a gay character write
funny about cancer you do it anyway
Christy Plunkett Jill's sponsor
but I'm not responsible for this
it was a big surprise to the viewers of
mom that the character of Jody played by
Emily Osmond had a fatal overdose and
died on the show at that point Jody had
reached six months of sobriety Lori has
said it was decided that Jody would have
an overdose when she was first
introduced to the show he explained the
reasoning behind this in an interview
with TV Insider recovery from addiction
is fragile the one day at a time Trope
is sadly true it's a vulnerable state of
being that requires vigilance you can't
ignore it the entire cast of mom was
heartbroken when they read the script
and realized that Jody was going to die
on the show not only did they love the
character but they loved Osment as well
it was a challenge for the writers of
mom to figure out how to bring tragedy
to the show and then go back to being a
comedy But ultimately Jody's death
showed that life goes on
laughter is contagious and the shared
experience of laughing can make a comedy
even funnier this is why it was so hard
to shoot mom when the covid-19 pandemic
took away its live audience
something I said changed the course of
your life for the better
it feels like it are you listening to
this veteran TV director James widows
who held episodes of mom agreed with
that assessment speaking to variety he
called shooting the sitcom during the
pandemic a logistical challenge like no
other Gemma Baker the co-creator of mom
told deadline that not having a live
audience was one of the hardest parts of
finally ending the series an audience
was so much a part of what we did and
this whole season we missed them it
really was a huge loss to not have that
energy and feedback and laughter it
would have been great if we could have
ended the season in front of a live
audience
when Anna Faris announced that she was
leaving Mom after seven seasons it was a
big shock to say the least and while
it's hard for a show to survive when a
lead character leaves it isn't unheard
of similar to Chuck Laurie's other hit
sitcom Two and a Half Men mom was able
to hang in there for a little while
longer putting out one more season
however co-creator Gemma Baker wishes
they could have done more with Christy
telling deadline there were so many
things that we wanted to address that we
didn't get a chance to if we had a
little more time we would have gotten
the chance one storyline fans missed out
on was seeing how Christy would have
done at Georgetown University law school
Baker described how she imagined it
Christy would have faced some challenges
But ultimately would have overcome them
Baker went on to tell deadline how she
envisioned closure for Christy I like to
think that Christy got into a happy and
healthy relationship and that she is
still a part of her mother's life
fans can have a lot of power when it
comes to saving a show case in point the
original Star Trek series about to be
canceled after the second season NBC's
Deluge of letters from fans begging the
network to keep it on saved it the cop
drama Cagney and Lacey has a similar
story after it was canceled a letter
writing campaign kept it on the air and
when Mom was officially canceled in
February 2021 fans mobilized with a 50
000 signature petition and those fans
who were in recovery were particularly
passionate to them it was important for
the show to remain on the air because of
the fact that so many addicts were
struggling during the pandemic as the
petition stated mom has been a crucial
voice in destigmatizing addiction this
show has no doubt saved countless lives
by promoting substance abuse recovery
and encouraging people to seek help
while the show did end up going off the
air the spirit of mom and how it gave a
voice to people in recovery will carry
on
a lot of sitcoms have endings where
everything ends up just fine and
everyone lives happily ever after but
for a show like Mom having everything
wrapped up with a neat little bow at the
end just wouldn't work
my name is Bonnie
and I'm a grateful alcoholic
co-creator Gemma Baker also didn't want
a convenient ending for the show telling
The Hollywood Reporter because of the
nature of the show it didn't feel
truthful to have an ending where
everything is tied up because the show
has always really been about reality and
characters showing up for Life On Life's
terms I think it's true what we say here
don't leave before the miracle
oh
Baker recalled how the finale was hard
to put together because they wanted to
bring the show to a close in a way that
was meaningful and that did the best for
the characters and the audience as well
a challenging feat even under the best
of circumstances made more difficult by
the sudden departure of the lead we'll
be there every step of the way
stay straight
and the characters and the creative
staff had to make the best of a tough
situation and deal with life on life's
terms forgiven
[Music]